I have this dog he's a doodle mix or  something but no but this is the problem  he's a rescue from Mexico I swear to God  but when we got him he looked like a rat  and then now everyone thinks I paid six  grand for him but he's not a six grand  guy I bumped into you and your wife on  the street yeah that's my golden doodle  I never like we want to go to Mexico  where I was like I like that they don't  shed because Muslims don't want dog hair  everywhere  uncovered  but if you want to cover cover you know  what I mean I think everyone should be  able to do whatever they want a lot of  that's going on in Iran she also find  out about Iran in like two three years  flagrant people there's something  happening in Iran and everyone's like  you know that happened in 22. you know  it was crazy in 2025.